salut c'est du de prêt tôt pour bolt
alors la question qu'on va le plus posé
je pense c'est
à propos de mon âge quel âge as-tu dans
chaque média j'ai jamais trop aimé
définit un peu mon âge parce que
justement il ya un système
d'identification et je trouvais ça un
peu avec un peu de recul et un peu de
distance de ne pas dire mon âge ça
m'amusait beaucoup ça m'amuse et sam
amusera j'espère et bien ce truc un peu
au dessus de trucs plus il est jeune il
faut qu'il soit très très jeune pour que
justement il y ait cette ce côté un peu
prodigieux de regarder mais regardez
c'est l'enfant prodige il est tout jeune
et il a fait quelque chose de folie et
justement à ces gens là je répondais que
j'avais 31 ans par exemple et donc du
coup je trouve qu'on a pour moi c'est
pas quelque chose qui nous qui nous
définit forcément qu'ils identifient et
je voulais justement un maximum de flou
là dessus pour pouvoir justement
raconter même à plus tard à 40 ans ou à
50 ans que j'ai toujours 20 ans et avec
un recul nécessaire pour toujours
pouvoir y faire des chansons dans l'âge
que je souhaite la plus grosse question
c'est est comment cette vivent en
banlieue et un peu ce mythe fantasme
même un peu de la banlieue méchante
tendu ma banlieue pour moi c'est un par
un
un paradoxe un peu il ya tout elle m'a
énormément appris elle m'a énormément
restreint elle m'a même en a énormément
fermés dans ce que je devais être
comment je devais être
comment comme on m'attendait à où je
devais être ou comment je devais me
placer et samassa m'a un peu enfermé
mais justement de plus tu pars et plus
elle te manque elle parce que c'est ton
éducation c'est là où tu as grandi et tu
es quand tu es vite tu vois pas
forcément tout ce que les autres peuvent
raconter sur le mythe de la banlieue un
peu dangereuse pour moi n'était pas
dangereuse vu que j'y vivais parfois
c'est un peu plus difficile justement
parce que c'est rempli enfin là où je
vivais en tout cas crette s'était rempli
de figure mal qui qui qui qui était sans
cesse dans le dominant dans la dans la
représentation de la virilité qui
voulait à tout prix à chaque fois prôné
quelque chose une sorte de
de vaillants des vaillants comme ça et
il ya juste ce côté là mais après y'a
aucun aucun c'est pas plus difficile de
vivre mon jeu je pense que de vivre en
campagne un peu ce truc un peu qu'on le
veuille ou non d'une sorte d' exclusion
il va falloir que il va falloir que
honteux mais un peu cette image là il va
falloir que tu donnes dix fois plus
parce que tu viens de banlieue il va
falloir que que thuram encore mille fois
plus par rapport aux gens de paris qui
ont des avantages et j'ai un peu
ressenti ça va dans l'éducation
la question qu'on m'a posée aussi c est
ce que je suis un artiste engagé par
rapport au fait que j'ai parlé dans cet
album d'homosexualité je pense que c'est
prétentieux de de pouvoir dire je suis
le représentant lgbt
j'aime pas trop cet immeuble à la main
je suis pas quelqu'un je ne ressens pas
de cette légitimité cette étoffe d'aller
dans la caricature militante qu'on peut
imaginer tels que le lever le poing
première ligne de front à les défendre
ses droits laisse ferrante ans cette
revendication un peu massif j'ai jamais
eu cette force là j'ai jamais sentie
cette fierté de communauté c'est pas
quelque chose de mon tempérament
le tempérament que j'ai plutôt c'est je
crois c'est justement de dire les choses
de manière un peu plus
à mon sens subtil par les mots par l'art
par la musique on cherche des figures
visuel l'image l'image on est beaucoup
là-dedans je crois donc dans cette
représentation de qui pourrait nous
représenter comme on pourra le
représenter moi finalement je suis que
le moteur le le le
comment dire le vecteur je suis je suis
que ça mais mais la force du truc c c c
est ce qu on propose à écouter est ce
qu'on propose à voir ce qu'on propose à
aller voir mais ça je parle pour tout
l'art en général
comment définissez vous votre style
musical ça c'est on l'a toujours
toujours poser encore une fois c'est une
histoire de deux définitions et aussi de
subjectivité dans le sens où certains
médias certains certaine presse me
catégoriser dans le côté rap d'autres la
variété d'autres la chanson j'ai même
entendu slam conteur d'histoires
vraiment c'est vraiment chanteur lyrique
on m'a même dit une fois il ya vraiment
plusieurs définitions et et cette
projection là moi je voulais en aucun
cas mettre quelque chose qui pouvait me
me cadrer meetic t pour un peu me figé
comme ça tout ce qu'ils peuvent figer
donc l'âge comme le style ou les choses
qui qui représente quelque chose je
voulais justement les prendre à
contre-pied elle est ailleurs
parce que parce que j'aime pas cette
idée de catégoriser qu' on n'est pas
qu'une chose on n'est pas qu'une
sexualité on n'est pas qu'un genre
musical est justement pour pouvoir aller
un peu n'importe où
[Musique]